Downing Street has just confirmed that
the Prime Minister Boris Johnson has
tested positive for a corona virus Boris
Johnson has coronavirus we don't know
about the rest of his household or the
whereabouts of his partner Kari Simmons
but mr. Johnson
has tested positive for corona virus we
can speak to our correspondent in
Westminster Rob Powell this comes at the
time of day when the government brief
political reporters about what's going
on and Boris Johnson's got it yeah so
this is a statement that's just been
sent out from 10 Downing Street
literally in the last few minutes
Downing Street spokesperson saying that
the Prime Minister had been experiencing
mild symptoms yesterday he was tested
for coronavirus on the personal advice
of England's chief medical officer
professor Chris witty it goes on to say
the test was carried out in number 10 by
NHS staff and the result of the test was
positive so in keeping with the guidance
the Prime Minister is self isolating in
Downing Street but is continuing to lead
the government's response to coronavirus
now the Prime Minister has been having a
meeting of his so-called 'war cabinet
this morning now we understand that we
didn't see any ministers or any
officials going into Downing Street this
morning and I think that was being held
on a telephone conference court we
obviously saw him late last night at
8:00 p.m. last night outside the front
of Downing Street joining in the clap
for the carers event he was stood quite
far away from I'm the Chancellor ashisu
knack who was there as well I think what
this Downing Street statement um is at
pains really to point out is that he
still is in a position to lead the
government's response to this and
pandemic outbreak there have been talk
about a week ago or so of who would take
over if any of the critical people
involved in this were to come down with
coronavirus with Cove at 19 and were to
be incapacitated to an extent that they
wouldn't be able to lead that response
it seems from what number 10 is saying
here that actually Boris Johnson is just
experiencing
mild symptoms so he may be able to work
remotely from isolation in Downing
Street and still leave that response but
I think it does ask beg questions about
where the prop where the Prime Minister
has robbed we've just had a tweet from
Boris Johnson which says that over the
last 24 hours I have developed mild
symptoms and tested positive for Coronas
virus I am now self isolating but I will
continue to lead the government's
response via videoconference as we fight
this virus together we will beat this
hashtag stay home save lives so that's
Boris Johnson a relatively cheery tweet
having tested positive for coronavirus